twitch band gambling those are three
words I thought I'd never be able to say
but with the kind of weak twitch has
been having I guess I shouldn't say I'm
surprised I mean they've been having
more drama than a Spanish soap opera I
mean scams gambling covering up
this feels like the world's worst game
of prison Bingo literal crimes have been
admitted to here and then three seconds
later nobody cares because somehow
something bigger has happened so look as
much as I want to believe that twitch
has had a crisis of conference here I
think the most logical explanation is
that twitch it just feels like they're
in the middle of some kind of a scam
criminal drama hurricane so they're just
looking for something anything to make
them look like they have control of this
situation I mean because honestly right
now they look like children trying to
Pilot a spaceship like let's push this
button and see what it does oh we banned
one of our biggest streamers so we're
gonna go over twitch's statement on
their gambling ban and basically the
start of it goes over their widespread
gambling problem the site has had and
basically what they plan to do on it
interestingly they seem to kind of admit
that their old system wasn't working
they say gambling content on Twitch has
always been a big topic of discussion
and something we've actively been
reviewing since our last policy update
in this area so the full lore on this if
you've been a long time time subscriber
is basically this isn't the first time
twitch has been criticized for this
we've actually personally been through a
twitch gambling Arc remember a year ago
mudahar and I teamed up to defeat the
gambling meta on Twitch and uh and we
failed because I mean okay yes everybody
left rubette right Steve will do it
stopped gambling for like a week and
then everybody moved over to steak and
you know it was even bigger than I mean
basically we converted everyone to from
beer to cerveza right it was like the
same thing different name anyways around
that time twitch issued a statement
because they were getting so much heat
about this whole gambling thing and you
know ruining people's lives because the
stories in gambling addiction are so
horrific so they had to do something so
twitch announced that they're going to
ban affiliate codes which basically
meant the biggest streamers couldn't
directly link their affiliate codes on
these gambling websites and make even
more money uh but this did basically
nothing because of course you can just
find the code two seconds you know it's
not hard so so now slots are basically
bigger than ever this year sites like
steak are pumping in millions tens of
millions to get the top streamers to
gamble on their website like basically
people like xqc and train wrecks are
full-time Casino employees essentially
and basically they're part of the reason
that slots are now a top 10 category on
Twitch literally they've had like 45
million watch hours just this month and
I know that number just seems impossibly
huge so let's compare to this fortnite
got a similar number of watch hours this
month too so yeah twitch's efforts to
curb gambling content or whatever worked
about as well as shooting a squirt gun
at a house fire and I guess they seem to
kind of acknowledge this when they say
some people circumvented those roles and
exposed our community to potential harm
like yeah no duh people circumvented
this role so twitch is basically saying
like Okay No More Mr Nice platform
they're going to take a harder stance
and uh they actually did in a weird
twist they decided to ban slots Dice and
roulette and are banning all the biggest
crypto casinos I mean this is big news
guys steak roll bet dual Bits And even
rubette who of course we've talked about
I mean this is a ballsy move by twitch
especially the fact they named daddy
steak first I mean they know exactly
who's putting the big dollars into their
platform
um and they know who's gonna affect the
most like for context stake is a billion
dollar organization they're huge they
sponsor the UFC but one of their biggest
like marketing vectors this whole time
has been that twitch slots section where
they had the biggest streamers just
working for them like 18 hours a day you
know serving up that hot gambling
content so this is a big move by twitch
to just cut it off right there like name
the platform and be like nope that's not
happening anymore I heard that Aiden
Ross is already sending out resumes so
rip to him but either way I don't want
to make this sound like it's the full
permaband I mean there are things not
included here like poker isn't going
away neither is sports betting or like
fantasy sports uh which you know is
probably because most people see them as
less harmful forms of gambling and
researchers say that they're less likely
to addict people
um and I think twitch kind of has a
point here right like poker is a game
invented thousands of years ago or
hundreds I don't actually know but slots
is like literally the results of humans
sitting in a research centers and like
tinkering how do we mix the perfect
dopamine cocktail for your brain right
there's actually a great book on this
called addiction by Design where it just
goes over how every part of a slot is
made to like hook your brain on it from
the second you sit down I mean don't get
me wrong you definitely can be addicted
to like these like lesser forms of it
but I I think it's not very arguable
that slots are the most important potent
form of gambling we currently have so I
guess the logic here is that they're not
going you know full black and white
they're just kind of drawing the line at
poker and sports betting and look
let's see perfect no but
it gets a legitimately Good Start
compared to like what they've done in
the past which is basically nothing and
I know it's going to anger some people
you know who are going to come in and
say you know what about personal
responsibility they have a point to this
and I want to address that because I'm
all for individual accountability at the
individual level like if you're addicted
yes you have to take personal
accountability no one's going to get you
out of your situation but when we're
talking about a platform right that
argument goes out the window because you
know who doesn't talk about personal
accountability when it comes to gambling
steak.com at no point in their revenue
share meetings are they talking about
like oh darn it you know people are just
taking too much personal accountability
we're losing Revenue here no they think
of people as statistics as they should
at their level they know you know if you
we want to pay xqc 10 million dollars a
year this is how many people we need to
get on our site and that percentage of
people we know exactly how many people
are going to spend a hundred dollars we
know exactly how what percentage of
people are going to get addicted and Etc
et cetera et cetera they don't view
things at the individual level because
they're a platform that would make no
sense in fact the only time gambling
sites talk about personal accountability
is when it suits them in the Press right
when it absolves them like of course the
people selling addiction want to talk
about how it's your job to not get
addicted and again like are they wrong
at the individual level they're not that
is the only way to solve individual
problems but if the way to solve
individual problems is at the individual
level what is the way to solve a
platform-wide problem well it's at the
platform level and that's what twitch is
finally doing I mean you can't just
ignore the fact your platform is the
gateway drug for a lot of people to get
addicted to gambling forever you know
and believe me Twitch has tried to
ignore this uh but they just can't
anymore so I definitely think this is a
step in the right direction
um but maybe most importantly no
definitely most importantly this is a
huge win for coffeezilla shareholders
some of you guys have stuck with me an
entire year when we fought this gambling
meta and uh to finally come out of on
top no thanks to me by the way because
we haven't talked about it in a while
but you guys stuck in with me some of
you invested pumped the stock pre the
rubette investigation split of 2021 I
mean your stock your Dividends are Sky
High and you know what uh you deserve it
okay seriously though thanks to everyone
who supported the content I mean I don't
say that enough uh but while reflecting
whenever things change like this it is
kind of amazing how much we've grown and
um I don't take it for granted thank you
guys so much for watching